[Music]
welcome back in this lecture we'll be
considering AC and DC now what's that
all about well so far we've dealt with
power sources that were largely
batteries and batteries have chemical
reactions that maintain basically a
fixed steady voltage across the
batteries terminals you plug something
into the wall and that's not what you
get what you get out of the wall is a
varying a time varying voltage and it
will drive a time varying current to
whatever you put there there's a good
reason why we use such alternating
current in power systems one is that
rotating generators naturally make AC
power the other reason is it turns out
to be easy to transform or change
voltage levels in AC systems so we can
step the voltage up to hundreds of
thousands of volts for long distance
transmission line and then back down to
relatively safe levels for use in the
home or in industries we're also going
to be looking at AC when we think about
audio signals and a lot of other signals
that vary with time but any electrical
signal that represents sound for example
varies with time so we want to begin by
looking at the waveform of basic
alternating current and that's called a
sine wave and one reason the sine wave
is useful is because it's simple to deal
with mathematically and also it turns
out that you can make any complex
waveform out of a sum of sine waves and
so let's begin by taking a visual look
at an AC voltage so here's an AC voltage
plotted as a function of time time is on
the horizontal axis the voltage V is on
the vertical axis zero volts is the
horizontal line through the middle
there's an arbitrary start to time I'll
call time zero and that happens to be
when this voltage is passing through a
zero on its way up and the AC voltage
rises to a peak comes back down again
through zero goes negative in other
words it reverses direction that's why
it's alternating goes to a negative peak
Rises back up and completes a full cycle
so we want to learn how to characterize
this AC voltage so first we're going to
talk about the peak amplitude that's the
peak value of the voltage that's the
voltage at the very maximum it's also
the opposite of the voltage at the very
minimum
sometimes by the way you'll see people
talk about the peak-to-peak voltage
which is twice the peak because it's
from the bottom to the top at least for
a voltage that swings symmetrically
about zero as this one does so there's
the peak voltage there's also something
called the RMS voltage root mean square
voltage that complicated language has to
do with squaring this waveform taking
the average of it and taking the square
root you do that because if you took
just the average you get zero because
it's up as much as it is down and it
turns out that for a sine wave the RMS
voltage the root mean square voltage is
0.71 times the peak voltage that's
actually the peak voltage divided by the
square root of two but we won't worry
about that so there's the RMS it's about
not quite - not quite three quarters of
the way up from zero so two different
ways of characterizing AC voltages in
terms of how much voltage there is now
we also are interested in the period
what's the time for one full cycle where
there's a full cycle from where the wave
starts out at zero rising goes up goes
through zero comes down and goes back up
through zero rising that's a full cycle
it's not a full cycle when it reaches
zero again because at that point it's
falling and it has to wait till it comes
back and that's a full cycle you could
measure a full cycle also from the
bottom most trough to the next bottom
most drop or from the top peak to the
next top peak all of those are the
period t the time for one cycle of this
sine wave and we also talked about the
frequency the number of cycles per
second that the sine wave undertakes and
the frequency is simply 1 over the
period the inverse of the period so
those tell you the same thing
frequency is measured in cycles per
second which is given a special name the
hurts after Heinrich Hertz so we'll talk
about either frequency or period when
we're talking about AC sine waves and
let me give you a demonstration of an
example of what some AC sound sine waves
look like on the oscilloscope and also
what they sound like so we'll switch
over to the oscilloscope here I have the
oscilloscope it's displaying on the big
screen it's also displaying on itself
and I'm feeding the oscilloscopes red
channel that's channel 4 with the output
of this function generator that we used
in the previous lecture to generate
those pulses for the speed of sound but
I have it set basically to generate a
simple signal at a frequency that is
audible so there you see the waveform
it's running at a fairly low frequency
of a few hundred it's running at 200
Hertz in fact and you can hear a low
tone coming out of a loudspeaker you can
see the oscilloscope is having a little
trouble dealing with this one was it
triggering but that's okay there's that
waveform there's one cycle of it
displaying on the oscilloscope screen
okay so now let's switch up to a higher
frequency two things will happen you'll
see more of the cycle fill the screen
we're going up to 300 Hertz and now we
see about one and a half cycles on the
screen and you hear the higher pitch
coming out of the loudspeaker 400 cycles
more 400 cycles per second five six
seven eight so there I'm adjusting the
frequency or period of the waveform I
could also choose to adjust the
amplitude the vertical height the number
of volts being output and let me do that
there it is coming down keeping the
frequency now constant but bringing the
amplitude down to lower and lower levels
so amplitude and frequency or amplitude
and period are the two things that
characterize an AC signal so before we
leave the subject of AC sine waves
altogether let me turn off this function
generator and talk about a very familiar
AC voltage at least familiar to people
in North America and that's 120 volt 60
Hertz AC power line frequency 60 Hertz
60 cycles per second one sixtieth of a
second is the period that 120 volts is
the RMS voltage the actual peak voltage
is about 170 volts so 120 volts RMS
about 170 volts peak I say that's
familiar to North Americans because if
you're in Europe you typically use about
230 volts and your frequency is 50 Hertz
which is one of the reasons you need
power converters when you go travelling
abroad so there's a familiar example of
an AC voltage and this is the one that
is supplied to us by the power companies
that all our electrical outlets here in
North America now there's a problem with
this AC voltage because electronic
circuits like we're studying in this
course like usually to work on DC
batteries are great for them but we
don't want to be lugging batteries
around all the time although these days
with smart phones and things that have
rechargeable batteries that's how we
power them nevertheless we need to get
DC to charge those batteries so somehow
we need to convert this AC into DC and
that's going to be the subject of the
rest of this lecture getting practical
making DC from AC and there's another
reason we need to do that also and that
is that circuits involving solid-state
components transistors typically run on
voltage levels of a few to a few tens of
volts 170 volts that peak of the AC
power line is far too much although I
will say tube circuits many of them
would have been very happy with that
voltage but transistor circuits
solid-state circuits
no so we've got to do two things we've
got to reduce the voltage and we've got
to convert it to DC the steady DC that
doesn't change with time and so we're
going to meet three new components that
are going to help us to do that
three new electronic components all of
which I showed you circuit symbols for
back in the lecture on circuits and
diagrams and so on but now we're going
to look at them in a little more detail
the first of them is the transformer now
the transformer is an interesting device
it consists of two coils of wire in
close proximity for the kind of
transformers we're talking about the
transform power those coils are
typically wound on an iron core and if
you've taken any other physics course
either from the grade courses or in
college or high school you probably
learned about the phenomenon of
electromagnetic induction whereby a
changing current in one circuit will
induce cause a changing current in
another circuit even though the two
circuits aren't connected and the
intermediary is the magnetic field
that's created by those currents I'm not
going to go into those details here
again in keeping with this being a
practical course I'm simply going to
introduce you to the transformer and
here we see it's circuit symbol though
you can see obviously what it is it's
the two coils of wire and those vertical
bars in between representing the iron
that those coils are typically wound on
to concentrate the magnetic field
between those coils so there's what the
circuit symbol looks like we have a v1
and a v2 the left-hand side is called
the primary the right-hand side is
called the secondary although those
names could be reversed it doesn't
really matter
so we have n1 turns on the primary and
n2 turns on the secondary and what
happens is z2 the voltage that appears
across the secondary is the ratio of the
turns in to over n1 times v1 so if I had
a transformer with the same number of
turns on both secondary and primary I
would get the same voltage out you might
say well that's not useful for anything
was very useful it isolates the
secondary from the primary a lot of
medical applications for example use
so-called isolation transformers that
don't step the voltage up or down but
they keep it roughly constant but they
isolate the circuit that might be
connected to the patient for example
here are some examples of transformers
they're ubiquitous there are huge
transformers at power stations which
step the voltage up for long-distance
transmission and step it back down for
safe use in it for end-users and cities
and towns by the way we don't get
something for nothing when we step up
voltage we get stepped up voltage true
but we get step-down current and power
is voltage times current and in
principle the power is the same either
way
there's a smaller transformer of the
type I'll show you in just a moment
there's a transformer a typical
transformer that you'll see sitting on
power poles around your neighborhood and
they supply one or more houses with
step-down voltages coming from maybe
seven or eight thousand volts on the
power line down to 240 volts for your
home and that's split into 220 volt
circuits and finally there's a power
block similar to this power adapter that
you see in common electronic equipment
there's a little transformer in there
sometimes in very small ones or some
other circuitry but usually there's a
small transformer especially if it's a
fairly hefty power block and then that
transforms the AC into a lower voltage
and often it also turns it into DC using
devices that we'll see shortly the
transformer I'm going to use today is
this one it's a small transformer I've
just got it mounted on a plastic block
and a couple of binding posts so I can
connect to it easily but the transformer
is the thing I'm holding in my hands
it's got this iron core and then
underneath those paper layers are the
windings the two coils and this
particular transformer is supposed to
take in standard 120 volt power line
there's a power line I'm going to
connect it to by the way don't go
connecting things to power lines it's
dangerous I know what I'm doing here and
normally people working with electronics
as hobbyists never have to touch the
power line or go near it their circuitry
already takes care of what I'm about to
do here so here's the power line coming
in and here is supposed to be six point
three volts RMS coming out that's a
common transformer used in the old days
to power the filaments in vacuum tubes
but it's also useful for a lot of other
purposes and I'm going to use it for
some of these purposes and so I'm going
to begin by doing some changes to the
oscilloscope that will allow me to look
at the voltage that is being produced by
that transformer so now I have the
oscilloscope set up to measure the
output of the transformer through this
wire which connects to channel 1 the
channel that displays in yellow I'm
going to connect the two wires to the
two outputs of the transformer and I'm
going to plug in the transformer and
let's take a look at what we have so
here we have a clear pattern that looks
pretty much sinuous oil it's not perfect
there's a bunch of electrical noise in
this studio and there's some other
issues going on here but basically it's
a nice sinuous oil waveform
approximately
it's running up and down about tears of
zero it's running up about ten volts
that's about two divisions you can see
at the upper left it says five volts per
that means each of these squares is five
volts so we're coming up about ten volts
I thought I said that transformer was
six point three volts it is but that's
six point three volts RMS that's that
average and so the peak is closer to ten
and so it's coming up to not quite ten
volts take point seven and standing you
get about seven and that's a little more
than six point three and so it's working
if you measure the time between these
Peaks you would find on this
oscilloscope at five milliseconds per
division it would come out a sixtieth of
a second so there is the output of the
transformer now swinging about plus and
minus 10 volts it's still AC but it's
now a lower level more appropriate to
the kind of electronic circuits we're
going to be building so we've taken the
first step in building a power supply to
take what comes out of the wall and turn
it into a suitable voltage to use to
power electronic circuits but we've got
two more steps to go through before we
can do that and I need to introduce two
new components in order to make those
steps so let's take a look at first the
diode I showed you a diode when I gave
you a bunch of circuit symbols a while
back in the second lecture now I'm going
to say a little bit more about diodes
but we'll really get some into them and
how they work a few lectures hence but
what a diode is practically speaking is
basically a one-way valve for electric
current it likes to current flow in one
direction in other words it has a very
low resistance in the so called forward
direction and it has a very high
resistance in the reverse direction
there is a circuit symbol for a diode
it's this solid triangle sometimes it's
drawn hollow with a bar current flows
through that diode from left to right
that's the direction of the current flow
if you put a positive voltage on the
Left you'll get current flowing through
it and it will act like a very low
resistance almost like a wire if you put
voltage the other way it won't work and
we're going to characterize the diode
like we did other circuit components
with a VI characteristic curve and here
is the VI characteristic for an ideal
diode an ideal diode if you put positive
voltage across it or try to huge amounts
of current will flow because it is after
all just like a short circuit like a
piece of wire it
almost no voltage to drive current
through it it's like a switch that's on
but if you put the voltage the other way
you can build up large voltages in the
reverse direction and no current will
flow because it's like an open switch
and it switches abruptly when the
voltage across it changes now nothing is
perfect nothing is ideal a real diode
has a curve that lets a tiny tiny bit of
current typically micro amperes nano
amperes or less flow in the back
direction so it's very small and it
allows a small voltage to build up
across it and that voltage for a silicon
diode which is what most diodes are made
of is on the order of six to seven
tenths of a volt and that's going to
come back to haunt us many times in this
course so there's the diode it's like a
one-way valve if you will for electric
current so there's a point seven volt
voltage that the diode maintains across
itself when it's passing current again
if you're dealing with a circuit where
voltages are big that's irrelevant but
if it we're dealing with a few volts
you've got to take that into account so
that's the diode so what I'm going to do
next is take my power supply now it's
the step-down transformer that I already
showed you that I have connected and
I've got out of it six point three volts
RMS about nine to ten volts peak and I'm
going to attach a diode and I'm going to
look again on the other side of the
diode at the output and see what that
looks like okay before I actually
demonstrate what the diode does in the
circuit let me say a little bit about
the circuit I have here here I have a
small white board with a lot of little
holes in it and those holes make
electrical contact and I've taken one of
those boards and taken the back of it so
you can see kind of how the contacts go
there are rows of holes that are all
connected together by these bars of
conducting material there are rows along
the edges that are all connected
together and we're going to wire almost
all our circuits from now on on these
boards and this is the first example of
that we'll get more sophisticated
examples as we move on and I'll be
plugging components into these boards
and I'll be doing it in such a way that
I connect the parts I want connected and
don't connect the parts I don't want
connected by plugging them into the
appropriate holes so I have one of these
boards mounted here and it's got
connections
these binding posts so I can bring in
signals from outside now there's some
more stuff on this board there are
actually three things on this board
there's the power supply I'm now
describing there's a regulator circuit
it makes it better and I'll talk about
that in a minute and there's actually an
audio amplifier and a loudspeaker and
we'll get to that by the end of the
lecture so let me begin by connecting
the power supply the input of the power
supply to the transformer so the voltage
from the transformer is now coming in to
there and now let me take the
oscilloscope which has this probe which
makes it easy to connect two little
points on these circuits and I'm going
to first connect I'm going to connect it
right here to the output of the diode
the diode is a tiny black thing that you
can barely see and I'm not even going to
bother to hold one up it looks like a
little resistor but without any stripes
on it and it's got a little bar at one
end and that indicates the end toward
which current flows okay so let's see
what we've got well you can see the
yellow curve which is the output of the
transformer going up and down an
alternating current and you can see the
output of the diode which is almost the
same that little difference is partly
due to that 0.6 or 0.7 volt drop across
the diode but it's following the AC
coming out of the transformer while it's
positive but as soon as the transformer
output goes negative the diode shuts off
it becomes an open circuit and it's no
longer passing current and so we get
zero volts at the output and then the
next cycle comes along and we get a
voltage that follows it and across we go
now you might say well we've made DC
what we have in the sense that we've
made a voltage that only goes in one
direction but it's far from steady and
it would sound awful and I'll show you
that at the end of the lecture if we
tried to power say a piece of audio
equipment with that signal so we need to
move on and we need to look at still
another component that we have to add to
our power supply so meet the capacitor
capacitor is a pair of conductors
separated by an insulator will be using
capacitors a lot throughout the course
and I'll be introducing more and more
about them but for now it stores charge
and energy the charge and voltage are
proportional so if you put a certain
voltage across the capacitor
get a certain amount of charge on the
plate and the capacitance C is the ratio
of how much charge you get for a given
voltage one Coulomb per volt is called
one farad which by the way is an
enormous capacitance and what capacitors
do is it takes time to flow charge onto
their place and so they slow things down
they introduce a time dependence in
electric circuits and the voltage across
the capacitor can't change
instantaneously so we have plus Q on one
plate minus Q on the other plate and
some corresponding voltage between the
two plates that's what a capacitor does
so we're going to use the capacitor as a
so-called filter in this power supply
we're going to use it to smooth out
these variations that we're seeing after
the diode so let me add a capacitor to
this circuit and I will take a fairly
big capacitor this is a 2200 microfarad
capacitor and I'm going to put it right
into the circuit okay so the capacitor
this big cylinder has been inserted into
the circuit and let's take a look at
what's happened and what's happened is
we have an almost perfectly steady DC
voltage there's a little tiny bit of a
blip where the voltage where the peak of
the AC comes in but it's pretty good
steady DC by the way that little blip is
called ripple and you have to decide if
you're an electronic circuit designer
how much ripple you can tolerate if you
buy a power supply of we rated for what
the ripple voltage will be what this
variation in voltage would be and
typically it should be a very tiny
fraction of the actual output voltage
and you'll notice we're producing a
little bit less than 10 volts as our
peak voltage coming out of this power
supply now we need to do something else
to our power supply and I've actually
already got it in there and that is so
we've connected the filter capacitor
again going from the diode back to
ground back to the returns the power
supply and we've got about own 8 point
something volts DC and then we connect a
load resistance and I've actually
already got a load resistance connected
in that circuit that's the thing to
which we're wanting to deliver power and
we need to size that capacitor we need
to make it big enough so that during the
time the AC has gone negative and the
diode isn't conducting and there's no
more charge or energy coming into the
circuit the capacitor can hold that
charge and energy for a long enough time
voltage doesn't decrease appreciably and
this capacitor is doing quite a good job
if I had a smaller capacitor from here
that voltage might have decreased quite
a bit and then come back up again and so
on so there is a power supply with the
filter capacitor in place and I'll show
you or I'll let you hear soon just why
you really want to have that filter
capacitor so now we've introduced three
new components the transformer the diode
and the filter capacitor and capacitor
in general and filter capacitor in this
case let's improve on this power supply
one more time and here I've got to
introduce something whose workings you
won't understand for a few more lectures
when we get into the lectures on
operational amplifiers you'll understand
how we'll be able to build a device like
I'm showing you down here at the end I
have a little tiny thing it looks just
like a transistor but it isn't it's a
little black piece of plastic with three
wires coming out what it is is a voltage
regulator an integrated circuit voltage
regulator it probably has something on
the order of a dozen transistors in it
and its job is to take an input voltage
that may be varying may not be the
voltage you want and produce an output
voltage that is fixed by the
specifications of that voltage regulator
and this particular regulator I've
chosen is designed to produce an output
voltage of 5.0 volts so let's see how
well it does so I have actually the
output of my power supply also going
into the input of that voltage regulator
and then I have the output of the
voltage regulator and now I'm going to
connect my oscilloscope across the
output of that voltage regulator so that
output is right here and there are a few
extra components connected to that
output let's see if we've got the right
place and connect to there and now we
see a very steady smooth DC voltage
exactly the kind of thing we would like
just a very slight little wiggle as we
go under the peaks here but hardly
noticeable that's a good power supply we
probably in fact with that electronic
regulator attached could have gotten
away with a smaller filter capacitor and
since capacitors
expensive that would have been a good
thing so our circuit now looks like
something with this electronic voltage
regulator attached and then we've got
our load resistance following that and
it's beautiful it's smooth it's DC and
furthermore if you notice we're at five
volts per division on the oscilloscope
that's one division we're up at exactly
five volts if I throw it into my
voltmeter I would see it read five point
zero one or five point o2 or something
both or four point nine eight pretty
close to five volts so we've built a
nice DC power supply now let's do
something useful with this power supply
instead of just looking at it on the
oscilloscope what you might want to do
with a power supply like this is to
power some kind of electronic circuit
and the circuit I've chosen to power is
a little audio amplifier and so the last
thing I have on this board and again
this is something we'll learn about will
actually build from individual
transistors a few lectures hence but for
now I'm going to simply point it out I
have on that board a small little
rectangular chip it's an integrated
circuit audio amplifier it's not a great
big power amplifier but it can put out
enough power to drive a loud speaker
that amplifier is set in that circuit
it's driving this loudspeaker that you
see here and it is not yet connected to
a power source this yellow wire brings
it its power but I'm going to connect
that yellow wire to the output of my
voltage regulator and then this
amplifier needs an input so I've taken
as my input my iPod and I just connected
my iPod to some wires that I can plug
right into this board and they're
plugged into the input one of them's
grounded and one's plugged into the
input terminal of that amplifier the
iPod is now playing but we don't hear
anything that's because we haven't
connected the power or the amplifier so
we'll plug that right into the output
and there's our newzik so we've got a
complete audio system built with an
integrated circuit audio amplifier and
we've also built the power supply that's
giving it the smooth steady DC that it
wants to have you'll notice that
occasionally there are loud pieces in
the music and they're probably drawing
so much current out of the regulator
that it can't
quite keep up the regulation if I turn
down the volume a little bit sounds a
little better and it's running a little
bit smoother although you see a few
glitches by the way that lovely music is
called starlight it's written and played
by my sister Helen Wolfson who's a
hammer dulcimer player and so that's the
music and now I raise the question what
good is this silver capacitor in the
power supply what's it good for what's
it all about do we really need this big
honking thing there well let me show you
what happens I'm going to do grievous
damage to my sister's music by simply
removing the power supply where
capacitor from the power supply so
here's the nice music playing that's
what we hear the what we're hearing are
the 60 cycle the 60 Hertz oscillation
almost the same as the oscillations we
heard when I did the speed of sound
thing but this is coming from the fact
that the system is unable to regulate
the filter capacitor can't hold enough
charge to take care of maintaining the
voltage to the regulator during the time
that the AC goes negative the regulator
is doing its best to regulate but it
can't regulate if it's not getting
enough voltage at its input and what we
hear instead of the beautiful music is
this of this every cycle the voltage
coming up and we get a little bit you
can kind of hear the music playing
underneath it but not very much so we
really do need filter capacitors in
power supply if we don't have them we
got a big problem and I'll just stick to
filter capacitor back
and back it goes and we get the
beautiful music again okay
so let's wrap up what we've done here is
learn how to convert alternating current
to lower voltage for solid-state
circuits and convert it to nice DC we
needed three more components to do that
the transformer the diode and the filter
capacitor we're going to see a lot more
of diodes and capacitors we won't use
transformers much more because they're
built in to the kinds of things we'll be
working with
now if you did the project in the
previous lecture you learned about how
to simulate circuits with some of these
web-based simulators and if you'd like
to extend your prowess to that I'm
asking you in the project for this
lecture to design a simple 5 volt power
supply it needs a hundred ohm load
resistance you're going to use a source
you're going to have to pick your
transformer you're going to have to try
different capacitors and see what
happens and you're going to have to
tweak your transformer to achieve about
5 volts I'm not letting you use one of
these electronic regulators and if you
want to as a sort of extra credit or an
extra learning you could add one of the
integrated circuit voltage regulators
similar to the one I did here that's
available in these circuits so I
recommend the project for this lecture
[Music]